[Music]
all right audience now with more
reaction to the bombshell Flynn document
release Senate Judiciary Committee
chairman Lindsey Graham senator I don't
know what else to say I mean is this we
said is this the biggest setup you've
ever seen and I am told by my sources
this is only the tip of the iceberg
there is so much more coming yeah
there's more comin yeah I think there's
more comin no it's pretty apparent to me
that general Flynn was a victim of an
out-of-control Department of Justice he
basically got railroaded is pretty
widely known that the Obama
administration didn't have much use for
general Flynn so Attorney General bar
needs to be complemented he's doing the
right thing he has three goals that I
share restore trust hold people
accountable who have engaged in
misconduct and right wrongs like general
Flynn and I believe eventually
Papadopoulos what is our goal
truth admission or to get him to lie so
we can prosecute him or get him fired
senator maybe I'm old school maybe I'm
old fashioned I don't know but you know
if somebody serves their country a lot
of that time in war zones for 33 years
protecting our liberty and our freedom
and our Constitution and our way of life
you would think that you would bend over
backwards not set him up not say you oh
you don't need an attorney when he
definitely needed one not brag oh I set
my agents in to take advantage of the
chaos something I never do or get away
with in previous administrations that's
the FBI director and deputy director
they didn't think he lied they made him
a plea after he went bankrupt sold his
house and said we're putting your son in
jail if you don't sign yeah general
Flynn deserved better from his
government he was willing to die for his
country the people who were involved in
this I hope will be held to account
Attorney General bar is beginning to
right wrongs there's a lot more coming I
promise you that everybody who signed
the FISA warrant against Carter page
will be asked
two-five before the Judiciary Committee
whether they come or not will be up to
them but they will be asked to come and
the goal is to make sure this never
happens again to any American must less
a war hero you know so many people we've
been unpeeling the layers of the onion
on this deep state for such a long
period of time and people would ask me
when are we ever going to get justice
I'm told we're very close now and a lot
of big things a lot of moving parts here
and I think it's very revealing some of
the things the Attorney General has said
I'm paying attention and some of the the
movements of the prosecutor Durham in
terms of hiring more staff
what do you glean from these statements
and these actions well these notes reek
of criminal misconduct I trust attorney
general bar to be fair to everybody
involved those being investigated but
his goal I know him very well is to
write the ship is to restore trust
that's been lost to hold people
accountable one of the worst things that
can happen in any democracy is for those
who are in charge of the law to take it
in their own hands for political
purposes and I think that's what's
happened here but time will tell but I
promise you that we're going to find out
how the FBI operated when they were told
by the Russian sub source in January
2017 the dossier is a bunch of garbage I
find it an impossible to believe that
did not work his way up bacome Ian
McCabe in January 2017 the person who
prepared the dossier for Christopher
Steele told the FBI is a bunch of bar
talk in here say they obtained two
warrants after that how could that
possibly happen premeditated fraud
against the FISA Court
I lied to a judge I don't think you
could get me out of jail you're a darn
good lawyer you Wow trey Gowdy it man
the great one Mark Levin and couldn't
get me out all right
senator Graham Thank You great work